hi everybody my name is jaime brambila
my company name is heat cbd and grace
health and wellness they're two separate
companies
heat cbd manufactures cbd products and
great self-enrollment is a practice
dedicated to teaching
interested patients about the clinical
use of cannabinoids
so in august of 2018 my wife nicole was
diagnosed with
stage 4 metastatic breast cancer we
learned that the cancer had eaten
through her four five and six vertebrae
and that she would require eight hours
final surgery to correct it
the metastases was the only thing
holding her neck up
when we got to memorial sloan kettering
in new york
the doctors had explained that her
standard of care most likely would
include
six rounds of chemo radiation
and many surgeries to remove the tumor
masses
so the outlook was looking very grim and
but nonetheless we we wanted to go
through it full force
so the ironic thing is that well before
this
we started in the cannabis field with
the delivery service in california where
we were working with patients that were
afflicted
with critical ailments everything from
epilepsy to autism
ms and cancer we made the decision to
focus on the medical
rather than the recreational doing part
from the responsibility from the people
looking for alternative therapies
so after nicole's diagnosis we decided
to go full force into understanding
uh the monster that cancer is and
how
[Music]
and so we never i never expected
uh the outcome of nicole's case
um but you know we decided to make this
a positive journey and that was nicole's
request
so that's what we did
so the presentation today is going to be
about raising awareness
and raising awareness about this is
successful implementation of natural and
plant-based medicines
used with standard of care for
metastatic breast cancers
so we know uh what we know about
cannabinoid streptains in the ketogenic
diet is that
when they're used with traditional
standards of care they're positive
additions
and so um why are they positive digits
well they
they work synergistically to improve the
patient outcome
so these compounds
uh offer a cytotoxic effect
as well as a palliative effect and the
more well-researched effect is
the palliative effect which will which
we'll discover
um later on the presentation we will
explain in current detail what science
understands about uh the effects of
these compounds
so a little bit of background uh story
so
cannabinoids exert cytotoxic and p and
palliative effects
uh by means of physiological modulation
through the endocannabinoid system
and our bodies are naturally able to
produce endocannabinoids which interact
with receptor sites within the
endocannabinoid system
and the purpose for this system is to
create the
state of homeostasis so all the
all the functions that the
endocannabinoid system
produces it are still unknown
and but what we've discovered so far is
that this system is intricately tight
almost every bodily function that we
have
silas simon and cylosine come from um
magic mushrooms and
if anybody is familiar with that uh
these compounds are in the class of
psychedelics known as tryptamines
and these compounds are agonists of the
5h25ht
serotonin receptor group which are g
protein coupled receptors and that means
that
the the receptor sites are anchored to
the cell membrane
so what we important thing to keep in
mind is that
gpcrs or g-protein-coupled receptors
have been identified
to perform a phenomenon called
heterodymerization
or crosstalk and that basically means
that
when there's a similarly structured
receptor
one receptor gets activated by an
agonist
and another one that is similarly
structured gets activated as well
without the use of the ligand so
ketogenic or low carb high fat diets
these have been studied
for their effects in our metabolism and
what what they've
been the researchers but they've been
able to identify is that ketone bodies
are produced in the liver
and our bodies are able to use them
instead of using glucose as fuel
so this has a profound effect on our
physiology
especially in our cell metabolism
anti-cancer mechanisms of action of
cannabinoids psilocybin and ketogenic
low-carb high-fat diets
so in this presentation we're going to
review is
what current science understands as to
the aforementioned compounds
i will briefly explain the
anti-proliferative anti-invasive and
anti-metastatic
mechanisms of each adjunct therapy
as well as the palliative effects
so we're going to start off with the
first uh hallmark of cancer
and that's proliferation what we
understand about
proliferation is that it hap it comes
after the cell is mutated
it's the first significant stage of a
cancer cell progression
and this is when cells start to divide
and reproduce to start forming the tumor
mass
one of the very important things to keep
in mind here in
proliferation research is a protein
called
akt also known as protein kinase b
and it's one of the most studied
molecular mechanisms of uh
because of its effectual potential
effects of on apoptosis
so the inhibition of akt protein uh
initiates a signaling pathway that
activates autophagy
and this internal leads to programmed
sultan also known as apoptosis so
in other words keep uh important thing
to keep in mind here is that if you turn
off akt
the cancer cell dies so
how do we know uh cannabinoids exert
antiproliferative effects well
in pre-clinical studies uh cannabinoids
uh have been studied for their pre their
pro-episodic effects the specific
mechanisms of how cannabinoids
exert all these effects on cancer cells
are still unknown
because the system is just too complex
there are many receptor sites and
many lightings uh involved in
endocannabinoid system function
and with a recent study from the
technion institute of israel done on
identifying the heterogeneity and
complexity of cannabis extracts as tumor
agents
we can see an example of that
so the more well-known mechanisms of
action
though research from the completence
university of madrid they published the
one of the most significant papers on
this subject uh
it showed that activation of cannabinoid
receptors triggers a signaling cascade
that causes cell apoptosis and it's done
through stimulation of endoplasmic
reticulum which creates
uh ceramide accumulation in the cell
so that that's that's the route on which
uh can happen
how can ambulance turn off akt and then
in another study that was published in a
later day from the same university we
can see that
the pro-apoptotic effects are
specific to erbb2-positive breast cancer
cells which we know are the her2 new
positive breast cancers so here we're
going to
show a slide uh just so you guys can see
the
the route the signaling wrap and here we
can see that er
stress is activated by the cannabinoid
receptors
that air stress uh activates
a process called the noble ceramide
the the nova synthesis ceremony and that
activates uh something called p8
which eventually activates something
called trip3
which eventually uh activates ckt
and starts the process of autophagy and
apoptosis
so what do we know are the
anti-proliferative effects
of psilocybin the tryptamines uh
such as cytosine psilocybin have the 19
have been observed to have
strong and medium-high immunomodulatory
anti-inflammatory and potentially
pro-apoptotic effects that may cause the
inhibition
of akt and
if any and if anybody of you are
familiar with the signaling cascades
called
mitogen activated protein kinase or
nuclear factor kappa b these are
signaling cascades that
regulate cell proliferation cell
differentiation and survival and normal
cells
so what they've discovered uh on
tryptamines
is that in lab models the
when serotonin receptors are activated
they also mediate heterodimerization
and they and that's the coordinated
crosstalk that we went over
uh before so this happens between map
case
uh including p38 me kkk1
erk and pa3 kinase akht
signaling pathways as well as nfkb and
so this
leads to an intricate fine-tuning of
inflammatory responses by changes of
cell signaling
and we speculate that that's how akt is
turned off by
tryptomines and in the next slide i show
an example of how
um that heterodymerization that
crosstalk happens when uh the five ht
receptors are activated and this
just kind of shows the the signaling
cascade that happens
in between so
the second hallmark of cancer is hypoxia
and one of the important things to
identify here is
an inducible factor called hif1 and
basically
what they've discovered what research
has discovered is that when areas of
severe oxygen deprivation
arise this is called hypoxia
and this happens in invasive tumors
after hypoxia happens uh there's there's
a
signal that occurs by creating f1
that stimulates angiogenesis and
angiogenesis is an important part of
uh cell progression because that's
basically when
vascular tissue starts growing into the
tumor cell mass
and lymphatic tissue and that's how
eventually this the cancer cells
uh escape to metastasize
so the next slide just shows a depiction
of how
hypoxia occurs and how the blood vessels
start
growing into the tumor mass to
eventually
form the metastases
so there are many studies that show that
cannabinoids
actually block heph1 and in pre-clinical
studies
the activation of what the
activation of cannabinoids in cancer
cells
cannabinoid receptors and cancer cells
has shown
to down regulate the expression of
several
pathways including v
egf itself and hypoxia inducible factor
f1
so the anti-angiogenic effects of
psilocybin
and cylistine uh cytosine is assumed to
be a metabolite of psilocybin
and it's assumed because the
pharmacology of psilocybin is not
yet well understood either but we know
that this belongs to
a class of psychedelics called
tryptamines and in pre-clinical studies
uh tryptamines have shown to have
positive and strong effects on our
physiology
including immunomodulation
anti-inflammation
anti-tumor effects and these also
include
blocking hif1 through sigma 1 receptor
activation so
tryptamines activate sigma 1 and that's
how
if one is blocked in the cancer cell
so now we reach the third hallmark of uh
cancer progression and this is uh
metastases and this is the final stage
of
um when a cancer i guess falls out of
control uh
the important mechanism here to keep in
mind is id1
and what we've understood about uh
breast cancers that express this
mechanism this
this agent id1
is that in breast cancers mammary
epithelial cells
expressing id1 are unable to
differentiate
they acquire the ability to proliferate
and they invade the extracellular matrix
so id1 is an important regulator of
breast cancer progression
that's why we're focusing on it today
and
so cannabinoids block id1
and out of all the agilent therapies
that we're discussing today
the one that counters iv1 uh that's been
discovered so far
is cannabidiol which is a cannabinoid
that has a low toxicity profile
and it down regulates id1 by modulating
erk and reactive oxygen species
pathways which eventually leads to id1
down regulation so
i don't know if you guys noticed but i
didn't touch on the ketogenic diets and
the first two hallmarks of cancer and
that's because
um ketogenic diets work on on a route
uh on themselves um they're separate
from
the routes that cytocyberan or
cannabinoids connector
and what we know about these diets is
that
they've been recently proposed as
adjuvant therapies for cancer treatments
because
they target an effect called the warburg
effect
and that's basically an effect that
describes
that cancer cells predominantly utilize
glycolysis
instead of oxidative phosphorylation
phosphorylation sorry
to produce atp and atp is very important
for cell functioning
some cancer cells lack the ability to
metabolize ketone bodies
because of mitochondrial dysfunction
and also the enzymes that that help
break down
the ketone bodies so the rationale
is providing the rationale in providing
a
fat rich low carbohydrate diet in cancer
therapies to reduce
circulating glucose levels and induce
ketosis so the cancer cells
are starved the normal cells adapt their
metabolism
to use ketones and so
another important part of this is that
ketosis therapy also
reduces insulin insulin like growth
factor which is also important for cell
progression so what
what are the effects the palliative
effects that we know about
so we know that these compounds have
been recognized as effective
palliative tools when used in
conjunction with
the usual standards of care
the results are that symptoms are
greatly reduced and in our anecdotal
experience
we've seen this uh time and time again
with patients that are able to choose
this
and that happens it's important to
stress this point because
uh even though with cannabis uh half of
the country
uh has already legalized the medical use
silas simon on the other hand
is only legal in two counties in our
country so
hopefully we'll be able to change some
minds today so that we can change that
as well
i'm going to go through some examples of
how these compounds are good palliative
tools
and so many studies have shown the
efficacy of psilocybin in cancer
patients
as agents to decrease the symptoms of
depression
caused by the side effects of standard
of care
so many studies have identified
that students have
established that simon and other
psychedelics have uh
very little physiological safety
concerns
but we still need to do more research
to figure out what the psychological
repercussions would
be um so in john
in one of the one of these studies
that came from johns hopkins university
they analyzed 51 patients that were
diagnosed with advanced stages of cancer
and what they found was that high doses
of psilocybin produce a significant
decrease in depression general anxiety
and anxiety towards death
it also produced an increase in quality
of life and optimism
and the important the important thing
here or the uh
thing that that is that creates the most
impact is that
after this these therapies were
administered the result
persisted even after um
six months after the um the therapy was
administered
so cannabinoids we know that
cannabinoids are
safe and effective relative tools um
people that have attended these
symposiums have
probably heard all about that and they
have very good
effects including an um antimatter
effect uh antidepressant
uh anti pain and the ability to induce
uh sleep um i just briefly covered those
just
just to talk talk to them talk to you
guys about them but
what i want to what i want to emphasize
on is the synergistic effect
that these produce with standard of care
and in
recent lab studies from the completency
university of madrid
in collaboration with zelda therapeutics
we've found
that when we combine cannabinoids and
estrogen receptor
targeted therapies for example cis
cisplatin or lapatinib in a petri dish
uh what it shows is a positive
additional antiproliferative
response in cell cultures
so
the safety and efficacy of the ketogenic
diets uh
well these strongly depend on the type
of tumor
that is being treated in the genotype uh
in
involved so
the information having a little mix up
with my science
so what we know
uh so far about these uh therapies
we don't have a lot of uh data on these
because
so far there's been just very little
clinical data
uh and single case studies that show the
results of what this
could do there hasn't been uh extensive
randomized
uh clinical studies yet but from the
little information that we have
we can we can see that
these these therapies don't have
evidence of interaction with standard
care this
most of the research conducted on these
has been conducted on glioblastoma
patients
but there's also been recent studies
that have found that patients with
breast cancer
equally benefit from these
so the following study that i'm going to
present is the case study that
um captures my my wife's story
and i'm going to briefly go through that
uh just to explain
what we did with her
okay so i'll briefly go through this
so protocols that were
that were used uh we used standard of
care
she went through treatment every four
weeks
uh since the time of diagnosis to
uh january of 2019 final diagnosis was
august 2018 so she would take an
infusion of taxation
and herceptin progenitor and herceptin
are the targeted therapies texas here's
the
chemotherapy uh we can see that she did
a ketogenic diet in addition to
supplements
borage omega oils those are precursors
to
endocannabinoids you know pertinent
adjuvants
if they can be used uh vitamin b12
glucosamine pea which is a ligand
of cannabinoid receptors
and pre probiotic uh
supplements and those we know now that
work in conjunction with the
endocannabinoid system
so the doses that we administered of
cannabis oil um
they're relatively high and we can see
that
during several during different stages
we
the amounts of cannabis oil that we were
dosing every day would fluctuate
and that's because uh we
you know through trial and error and
through our method we were exploring
with different uh cannabis strains and
these were all whole plant uh cannabis
extracts we can see that
the use of psilocybin she had so she
she had two heroic um
sessions with psilocybin one happened in
november 2018 the other one january
2019 right before
she went for the pet scan that
determined that she didn't have
metastatic disease anymore and then
here we can see the images right we can
see the images of when the cancer
was initially diagnosed and we can see
the mass in the center
and then this is the pets underneath
that that's the pet ct scan that showed
no evidence of metastatic disease and we
can see clearly that the mass
has shrunk significantly
so what are the results
so so she was diagnosed in september
uh september 2018 the end of august
uh so by october 2018
50 of the mass was visibly reduced
uh her doctor could visibly see that 50
of the mass was reduced
by october january 2019
uh pet ct scan confirmed no evidence of
residual cancer
or recurrent disease and that persisted
today
so in breast cancer patients
tarsus mom is one of the best and most
recent advances
in the treatment of her2 positive breast
cancer and although this strategy has
been very successful
the statistics show that about 75
percent of the patients
with erbb2 over expressing tumors
do not respond to tarstuza map and the
ones that
do respond which is almost 15
eventually develop metastases
so this is why there's a need
a tremendous need to develop novel
therapeutic approaches so that we can
improve
patient survival in these patient
populations
there are many important benefits to
initiating observational clinical trials
to test
these therapies but so far little
attention has been given
to do so and with correct research and
proper clinical protocols
minor side effects that can occur can be
managed and accurate doses can be
studied so that we can deliver proper
therapeutic benefit
so now now we're going to talk about the
economic viability of producing
an observation clinical trial using
cannabis oil in contrast
to the cost and time frame to produce a
cancer drug
so we went we went through an exercise
using
nicole's case study as an example
um and we used the parameters from the
case study the amount of oil that she
took
and the time frame and we went
into weed maps we took a little survey
to figure out what a gram of oil uh
could cost and so two grams of oil is
what we considered
for you know a clinical trial to prove
whether or not these
these therapies have have these effects
and what we came up with
is that so we did a rough estimate
and the cost on a daily basis for uh
for a patient using this this therapy
can range from sixty two dollars per day
to a hundred a 120 per day and so
considering the five months that this
cost
um can range between ninety three
hundred dollars
and eighteen thousand four hundred
dollars roughly
so now now we're going to observe a
study that was published in the journal
of american medical association
and jama in september of 2017 and it
analyzed the investment and return of 10
different cancer drugs that were
recently brought to market
from separate developers so what this
study concluded
was that the average time frame to
develop a cancer drug
was 7.3 years that's a considerable
amount of time
the median cost uh the medium r d cost
and they broke it down into three
categories because there are three
uh you know categories um
in the in the drug development uh
pipeline right so
novel or self-originating drugs those
are drugs that discover
uh new novel uh targets and cancer cells
those
um the medium r d cholesterol is 899
million dollars uh next in class which
is
uh a step above the science of what we
currently understand so these are drugs
that
develop the science that we currently
know a little bit better and those
the medium r d cost is 473.3 million
dollars
and then we have acquired drugs on the
low
side of the totem pole which those cost
328.1 million
dollars so that's the r d cost now
all together and we know that r d plays
a big role
in price for drugs uh
the median cost to bring a cancer drug
to market was 648
million dollars and obviously this is
this is an
immediate estimate um there was a lot of
uh range in in between those numbers
so with all this
with all this that we know if we can
convince our lawmakers and medical
professionals to
give the described therapies the
recognition they deserve
and facilitate regulatory and financial
conditions to research the true medical
potential of these compounds
we can assume that these results would
impact
lowering of cancer drug costs lowering
of research and development cost
increasing quality of life of standard
of care
and the increase of quality of life
through pre and post cancer treatments
for patients
and with that i want to just uh
thank the team uh at the end of this
presentation for
all the hard work that we did together
um
bringing this case study um
to to light and uh here in the picture
we have dr sulak
lindsey myself caroline and
tom my wife uh next to tom there
so thank you guys